Many children have no food to eat
and these children are starving for an education!
It is alarming that 57 million children
are deprived of education.
They cannot go to school.
This must shake our conscience.
Girls have been the target of sexual violence
and abuse and they are only limited
to the four walls of their houses.
There is no freedom.
But still, there is hope.
I'm hopeful the European Parliament
will look beyond Europe, to the suffering countries
where people are still deprived of their basic rights.
The powerful country should not be judged
by counting its soldiers and Navy.
But rather, we must see which country
has the highest literacy rate,
which country has more educated people,
which country has provided the basic rights to its citizens.
A country with talented, skillful and educated people
is the real superpower,
not the country with tons of soldiers and weapons.
I'm hopeful that through our unity and determination,
we can achieve our goals
and help those 57 million children
who are waiting for us.
And these children, they do not want an iPhone,
an Xbox, a PlayStation or chocolates.
They just want a book and a pen.
Thank you so much.